المحللين
السياسيين من رام الله دكتور مصطفى البرهي
الامين العام للمبادره الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه من رفح الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
اياد القره وم واشنطن ويليام لورنس
المسؤول السابق في الخارجيه الامريكيه ومن
القدس الكتور محمد هلسه الاكاديمي والخبير
في الشؤون
الاسرائيليه نبدا معك اولا دكتور مصطفى هل
كنت توقع هذا الرد من قبل حماس لا احد
يعرف
بالضبط
مضمون هذا الاتفاق ولكن هل هل ترى بان
الان الكره في الملعب
الاسرائيلي بالتاكيد نعم انا كنت اتوقع
هذا الرد
وطبعا في ثلاث امور اصبحت واضحه اليوم بعد
المؤتمر الصحفي وبعد رد المقاومه الامر
الاول ان اسرائيل فشلت في تحقيق اهدافها
بالقوه العسكريه فشلت في اقتلاع المقاومه
فشلت في استرداد الاسرى فشلت في بسط
سيطرتها وفشلت في التطهير العرقي الذي كان
هدفا رئيسيا
لعمليتها اذا الان رد المقاومه الامر
الثاني رد المقاومه يجمع بين امرين الحاجه
لوقف العدوان ووقف اطلاق النار بشكل كامل
ومطلق ومراعاه الاحتياجات الانسانيه
لابنائي وبنات شعبنا الان في قطاع غزه
الذين يعانون الامرين من ظروف انسانيه
قاسيه جدا ومن بطش اسرائيلي مجرم اودى
بحياه ما لا يقل عن 33000 شهيد حتى اللحظه
معظمهم او الغالبيه الساحقه منهم من
المدنيين بالتالي الرد هو يجمع بين الحاجه
السياسيه لفرض اراده المقاومه بوقف
العدوان وفي النهايه سحب القوات
الاسرائيليه من قطاع غزه وبين تلبيه
الحاجات الانسانيه عبر هدى ربما تكون مت
والاليه ومتواصله تؤدي في النهايه الى وقف
اطلاق النار الامر الثالث الذي كان واضحا
هو الانحياز الامريكي المطلق لاسرائيل
فيما قاله بلينكن وهذا تجلى في ثلاثه امور
مهمه جدا اولا هو يتحدث عن الهجمات على
اسرائيل
والاعتداءات على اسرائيل والهجمات على
القوات الامريكيه لم يذكر بكلمه واحده
الهجمات الاسرائيليه على
الفلسطينيين لم يذكر بكلمه الاحتلال
لم يذكر بكلمه الاستيطان لم يذكر باي شيء
حقوق الفلسطينيين ابدا كله اسرائيل وامن
اسرائيل وحاجات اسرائيل ثانيا هو تحدث عن
حاول ان يجمع ولاحظ هنا الترابط بين ما
قاله بلينكن وما قاله الناطق العسكري
الاسرائيلي تحويل الامر من معركه بين
الشعب الفلسطيني والاحتلال الاسرائيلي الى
معركه بين الولايات المتحده واسرائيل
والعالم مع ايران كانه المش مشكله ايران
القضيه هنا انه يحاول ان يركز على اعراض
ظهرت نتيجه العدوان الاسرائيلي على غزه
ومنها ما جرى في اليمن والعراق وسوريا
وينسى المرض الرئيسي وهو هذا العدوان يعني
وهو يعرف تماما انه وقف العدوان
الاسرائيلي على غزه ووقف اطلاق النار
سيوقف كل الهجمات الاخرى اذا هو يحاول ان
يشوه الصوره القائمه ليعف اسرائيل من
مسؤوليتها
الاجراميه التي وصلت الى حد ات ن قال بانه
يعني المؤمل من هذا الاتفاق ان يوقف اتساع
رقعه النزاع في
المنطقه طيب اذا ليسمح هو ورئيسه باتخاذ
قرار بوقف اطلاق النار بس في مظهر ثالث
كمان لما قال ويظهر الانحياز الاسرائيلي
اللعبه القديمه عندما تحدث عن تطبيع فوري
مع اسرائيل مقابل مسار زمني مسار زمني
يعني اوسلو جديد
مسار زمني قد يمتد 30 عاما او 35 عاما
جديده دون ان تحدث دوله فلسطينيه وايضا
الحديث عن دوله فلسطينيه بانماط مختلفه مش
بس نزع نزع سلاحها نزع سيادتها هذه هي
المشكله يتحدث عن اسم دوله ولكن في
المضمون لا دوله حقيقيه وكل التركيز هو
كيف يستخدم هذا المسار الزمني لتمرير
تطبيع مع المحيط العربي على حساب القضيه
الفلسطينيه وطبعا في القضيه الرابعه
المهمه جدا ويعني طبعا ذكرها رئيس الوزراء
القطري مشكورا وهو موضوع وكاله الغوث
الدوليه كيف تتورط الولايات المتحده
بقياده تحالف يضمن 16 دوله
لمحاصرته الغوث الدوليه وهي تعرف انها
الوكاله الوحيده القادره الان على تنظيم
المساعدات الانسانيه لاهل غزه فيما يشكل
هجوما مش على وكاله الغوث وانما على حق
اللاجئين في العوده على على كل حال الرد
المقاومه على اسرائيل هو فتح للتفاوض وهذا
يعني ماذا اسرائيل فشلت في اقتلاع
المقاومه ومضطره الان ان تتفاوض معها كما
جر جرى في المره الاولى طبعا هناك اتجاهات
خطيره في اسرائيل قد تدفع الامور نحو
تصعيد عسكري هذا وارد لانه لدينا حكومه
فاشيه ولدينا نتنياهو الحقيقه يعني ما او
حاول يعني ان اخذ تفاصيل حوله من الدكتور
محمد هلس الاكاديمي والخبير في الشؤون
الاسرائيليه دكتور يعني بالنظر لما جاء في
بيان حماس وحديث ايضا رئيس وزراء وزير
الخارجيه القطري عن رد ايجابي كما قال
لحماس وقال بانه يدعو الى التفاؤل هل يعني
ذلك ان مصير هذه الصفقه هو الملعب
الاسرائيلي فعلا ام ان النقاشات الان داخل
الحكومه الاسرائيليه والتبيان داخلها
والمتطرفون ايضا سيفشلون هذه
الصفقه ايه مساء الخير ال الواضح بان كره
النار تعود الى الاقدام الاسرائيليه
تتدحرج الان بين اقدام نتنياهو ويمينه وا
متفقون جميعا بان نتنياهو يود وكان يتوق
ويود من المقاومه ان تقول لا ولا مدويه
وهذا يمكنه من استمرار الهروب الى يعني ما
يريده يودوا في منع توقف هذه الحرب الان
وقد قالت المقاومه كلمتها كما قيل بانها
يعني ليست نعم مطلقه وليست لا مطلقه انما
هو كما قيل يعني رد ايجابي يدعو الى
التفاؤل وهذا يعني يدعو الى مزيد من البحث
والتفصيلات وهذا ما لا توده اسرائيل ويذهب
الاعلام الاسرائيلي الان وجزء من
السياسيين الاسرائيل للقول بان حماس لم
تقل لا ولكنها قالت نعم ولكن بمعنى انه
هذا الرد سلبي يحاول نتنياهو ان يعني يلوي
اعناق الرد ويصوره للمجتمع الاسرائيلي
وللعالم على انه لا بشكل او باخر وسيسعى
وسيذهب في هذا المسعى لان يعني هذا الذي
جرى من المقاومه فيه احراج لنتنياهو لانه
يريد الهروب من خلال لا مطلقه من قبل
المقاومه الموضوع امام نتنياهو الان سيزيد
في حرجه مع الداخل الاسرائيلي لان الموقف
لم ياتي برفض مطلق والتفصيلات والحيثيات
التي ربما طرحتها المقاومه يكمن او تكمن
الاجابه فيها على مسعى نتنياهو او طريقه
نتنياهو في التملص من هذا الامر اعتقد بان
نتنياهو سيذهب الى كما قلنا قبل قليل
محاوله اظهار ان رد المقاومه مهما كان
طبيعته س يصور للمجتمع الاسرائيلي على انه
استسلام وهزيمه ولن يقبل بهذا الاستسلام
والهزيمه
المخرج اعتقد بانه في تعاظم يعني الحاله
الداخليه تفكك الحاله الداخليه وتشظي
الحاله الداخليه بالتاكيد هذا سيزيدها
وايضا في طبيعه الموقف الامريكي ربما
التلويح في قضيه التطبيع التي اشرتم اليها
قبل قليل
واستمرار الضرب على هذا الوتر الان ياتي
في يعني ان يزيد من احمال نتنياهو وكانه
نوع في مقابل الضغوطات الداخليه نوع من
الاغراء لجر نتنياهو الى مسار يعتبره يعني
بمثابه انجاز عظيم جدا في اطار علاقته مع
العرب والمحيط العربي وتحديدا مع السعوديه
لدفعه الى التنازل عن بعض الجزئيات
المتعلقه في استمرار الذهاب الى هذه الحرب
حتى نهايتها الولايات المتحده تسعى من
خلال هذا الفعل من خلال هذا المسعى من
خلال هذا الطرح الى جر نتنياهو واستدراجه
ل يعني التملص من اشتراطات واشتراطات ين
المتطرف حماس يعني تع عرف ماذا تريد وربما
ل تنطلي عليها مثل هذه المواقف اسمح لي
اتحول الى ويليام لورنس المسؤول السابق
الخارجيه الامريكيه ومعنا من
واشنطن سيد
لورنس واضح بان هناك حكومه متطرفه في
اسرائيل سيلتقي بها غدا بلينكن لبحث الرد
حماس وقد يدخل الجانبان في نقاش ولكن سبق
هذا اللقاء وهذا وهذا الرد من حماس
انتقادات وجهت لواشنطن رفض لوقف الحرب
بغزه حديث عن وضع منطقه عازله في غزه حديث
عن ترتيبات لبقاء اسرائيل في غزه ووزراء
ضمن حكومه نتنياهو يدعون لعوده المستوطنات
الى غزه هل ستسقط كل هذه ايه المطالب التي
تقدمت بها ايه ق تقدم بها اعضاء في
الحكومه الاسرائيليه
غدا من كل هذه الامور التي ذكرتموها لها
اهميتها وتعلمون ان
بنفير وسموت رغم
انهما تحدثا كل كثيرا وكلما اتيحت لهما
الفرص
لكن مع ذلك هما ليس جزء من المفاوضات هما
ليس جزء من كابينه الحرب ف طبعا اب
نتنياهو يسير صوب اليمين وصوب ما يقولان
لكن بالنسبه للامريكيين هم سئموا من هذه
الالاعيب
يريدون انهاء هذا الامر القطريون لعبوا
دورا مهما للغايه والمصريون كذلك هم
يريدون انهاء هذه القضيه من خلال اخراج
الرهائن
والمساله صارت جزا من الاستراتيجيه
الامريكيه لكن اعتقد هناك تركيز زائد عن
الحد على الوضع الداخلي في اسرائيل
والمواقف السياسي حتى انا اتحدث عن ذلك
كثيرا لكن ما سينهي هذه الحرب هو ان تقول
امريكا لاسرائيل ان من مصلحه اسرائيل
استراتيجيه ان تنهي هذه الحرب وكل هذه
المقترحات الاسرائيليه حول منطقه عازله
واستمرار الاحتلال وهذه لا فرصه لها لان
الامريكيون
يرفضونها جمله وتفصيلا ما لم يقرر
الامريكيون ان يسلموا زمام الامور كلها
لاسرائيل لكن الولايات المتحده للمره
الاولى في عقود تتحدث بشكل جاد عن الدوله
الفلسطينيه اعتقد ان هذا ليس من باب
الحديث الشكلي ربما هناك مغزى ولانهم يرون
ان الحل الافضل ان تكون هناك هذه الدوله
الفلسطينيه وان يكون هذا جزء من الحل رغم
ان الاسرائيليين لا يرغبون في ذلك لذا على
الامريكيين ان يجعلونهم يقبلون بذلك لا
نعرف اذا كان يعني الجميع سيقبل بهذه
الصفقه بانتظار
الان الموقف اسرائيلي وغدا لنظره قريب
اسمح لي اتحول الى السيد اياد القره
الكاتب والحل السياسي معنا من رفح سيدي اد
الطرف الثاني وهو حماس قدم هذا اليوم
وصفته قطر على لسان رئيس الوزراء وزير
الخارجيه بانه رد ايجابي يبعث على التفاؤل
ولكن الحقائق تقول على الارض بان حماس هي
تقاتل منذ اربعه شهور وبنفس القدره كما
يقول المحللون العسكري عسكريون فهل ترى
بانها هي من يضع المحددات ام ان الجانب
الاسرائيلي هو من يريد ان يملي محدداته
وفق تشكيله وتركيبه الحكومه الاسرائيليه
المتطرفه التي يتزعمها
نتنياهو اسعد الله اوقاتكم بالتاكيد
الصمود المقاومه وقدره الحماس على اداره
المواجهه على مدار ما يتجاوز من 120
كان عامل مهم في التعامل مع الاحداث
وتقديم رد حركه حماس بهدوء يمكن ان نقول
رغم الضغط التي تعرضت له خلال الايام
الماضيه فيما يتعلق بالاسراع بالرد وشكل
هذا الرد لكن استطاعت ان تتجاوز هذا الامر
بان تقدم رد بطريقه يمكن ان اعتبرها ذكيه
جدا بحيث انها كان ردا ايجابيا لكن اضيف
له الملاحظات التي كان يجب ان تكون جزء من
اي اتفاق يمكن ان يكون لاحقا وخاصه ما
يتعلق باطار ما يعرف اطار الاتفاق في
باريس الجانب الثاني هو مرتبط حقيقه انه
حماس او صمود الفصائل الفلسطينيه
والمقاومه في غزه افشل اهم هدف اسرائيلي
كان هو يتعلق بسحق حركه حماس وهذا لم يعد
موجود ولم يعد مطروح وانه بعد 120 يوم لم
تستطع اسرائيل من القضاء على حركه حماس
وارتكبت كل ما ارتكبته من مجازر اباده و
تدمير واسع للممتلكات وغيرها لكن لم تنجح
في القضاء على حركه حماس سواء على الصعيد
العسكري او حتى على
الصعيد الحكومه او العمل اداره قطاع غزه
رغم ما تعرضت له من ضربات وشاهدنا اليوم
استهداف اسرائيل لافراد الشرطه مجرد لانهم
افراد شرطه لمنع حركه حماس من العمل
الحكومي الجانب الثالث ايضا هو يرتبط بانه
حركه حماس ايضا تمكنت من الاحتفاظ بال
الاسرى في قطاع غزه على مدار 120 يوم من
كل الجهود التي بدلها الجيش الاسرائيلي
والذي استطاع ان يسيطر او يدخل الى عمق
مناطق قطاع غزه لم يتمكن من الوصول الى
هؤلاء الاسرى ولم يستطع ان يقدم
اي دليل او اثبات على حتى حياه هؤلاء
الاسرى في قطاع غزه هذه العوامل بتقدير
كانت عامل صمود في مواجهه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه التي استخدمت كل شيء لا شك
كما تفضل الضيوف الحكومه اليمينيه
المتطرفه الفاشيه التي تدعو الى ال احتلال
قطاع غزه واقامه المستوطنات في قطاع غزه
واقامه منطقه عازله وغيرها بالنتيجه
يعرفون جيدا انه اسرائيل ستذهب الى اتفاق
لكن شكل هذا الاتفاق هو س تحدده الايام
القادمه من عمليه التفاوض المرتكزه بشكل
اساسي على ما قلته في عناصر القوه التي
امتلكتها حركه حماس والفصائل في قطاع غزه
وا استطاعت ان تعمل بحاله من الاتزان حتى
اليوم في مواجهه هذه الحرب وانه هذه الحرب
الان نحن نستطيع ان اقول في مراحل متقدمه
باتجاه انه لم يعد لاسرائيل اكثر ان تفعل
اكثر مما فعلته سواء على صعيد الجيش
الاسرائيلي الذي ارتكب كل هذه المجازر او
حتى التهديد بالذهاب الى مدينه رفح الذي
التي اليوم تضم ما ما يتجاوز من مليون
فلسطيني نزحوا الى الى الى هذه المدينه
هذه العناصر الضغط التي تريد اسرائيل ان
تمارسها على الفصائل بتقديري لن تستطيع ان
تحصل على نتائج على ما حدث في خلال ال 120
يوم الماضيه ولم تنجح في الحصول عليها
خلال ايام من عمليه التفاوض لكن هذه المرح
المرحله هي مرحله ح عض الاصابع المقاومه
استندت الى عناصر القوه التي تحدثت عنها
اضافه الان الى انه يمكن ان نسميه عنصر
الوسطاء الذي يمكن ان يعتبر ايجابا بحيث
انه الرد الذي قدمته حركه حماس هو الان
وضع بين يد الوسطاء خاصه مصر وقطر في
امكانيه التحرك بشكل اكثر مريح وهي حماس
بالمناسبه في الهدنه الانسانيه الاولى
ايضا ابدت مواقف ايجابيه شاهد فيها
الوسطاء انه حركه حماس التزمت بما تم
الاتفاق عليه بينما اسرائيل لم تلتزم بذلك
وقامت
بانتهاك الهدنه الانسانيه والعوده الى
القتال بطريقه اكثر شراسه من ما حدث في
الفتره الانسانيه وهنا نذكر قرارات
وتوصيات المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه دكتور
مصطفى
البرغوثي هل تعتقد بان هذه الصفقه هي حاجه
اسرائيليه بالدرجه الاولى للخروج من معضله
وهي عليها ان تقدم تقرير للمحكمه العد
الدوليه بانها ستلتزم
ب تلك القرارات التي اتخذت في خلال
شهر بالضبط اخ جمال هذا عامل خارجي مهم
جدا يضغط على اسرائيل لانه اسرائيل التي
تواصل عمليات القتل والاجرام وتواصل حرمان
الناس من المساعدات الانسانيه بسييطه هي
تخرق قرارات محكمه العدل الدوليه وكما
قلنا من قبل تنفيذ ما ق ا قرته محكمه
العدل الدوليه لا يمكن ان يتم الا بوقف
تام لاطلاق النار اي الوقت يمر واسرائيل
ستواجه باحتمال انه بعد نهايه الشهر ان
تاتي محكمه العدل الدوليه وتصدر قرارا
يامرها بوقف اطلاق النار هي ستحاول ان
تتجنب ذلك لذلك هذا عامل خارجي مهم في
عامل خارجي اخر مهم وهو حاجه بايدن لوقف
هذه المعركه الان بايدن على وشك ان يخسر
الانتخابات اذا كانت هذه المعارك ستظل
مستمره بس في ايضا اخ جمال عوامل داخليه
اسرائيليه تضغط عليهم شكرا الدكتور مصطفى
البرغوثي الامين العام للمبادره الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه متحدثا من رام الله شكرا لك
شكرا للاستاذ اياد القره الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي كان معنا من رفح وشكرا ل ويليام
لورنس المسؤول السابق في وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه كان معنا من واشنطن وشكرا
للدكتور محمد هنس الاكاديمي والخبير في
الشؤون الاسرائيليه شكرا لكم